lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
descubrir si hay alguna forma rápida
para calcular la suma de las raíces de
cualquier polinomio y de hecho lo hay y
por eso estamos haciendo este vídeo así
que empecemos con el polinomio de
segundo grado digamos pensemos en un
polinomio muy general digamos x cuadrada
más a 1 x donde aún no es alguna
constante más a 2 igual a 0 muy bien
entonces tú dirás bueno oye y por qué si
querías poner un polinomio de segundo
grado tan general aquí porque este
coeficiente es 1 y te voy a explicar por
qué suponte que tienes el polinomio a x
cuadrada más b x + c igual a 0 entonces
en realidad aquí lo importante es
calcular las raíces verdad entonces
podemos dividir
de ambos lados / a entonces dividimos
entre a dividimos entre a todos estos
sumando si dividimos 0 entre a que sigue
siendo 0 esto sigue siendo 0
el detalle aquí es que estas se cancelan
y nos queda algo de la forma de x
cuadrada más algo por x más algo que es
justamente con lo que empezamos entonces
déjenme quitar todo esto y seguiremos
con nuestro procedimiento muy bien
entonces digamos que este polinomio de
segundo grado sabemos que tiene dos
raíces vamos a llamarles a digamos r1 y
r2 r1 y r2 son sus raíces que significa
que son sus raíces pues esencialmente
que esta ecuación la podemos ver de la
siguiente forma x menos ere uno que
multiplica a x menos r2 es igual a 0 muy
bien entonces si nosotros empezamos a
desarrollar este producto de binomios
entonces lo que vamos a obtener lo
siguiente x por x nos da
es cuadrada muy bien x x menos r2 es
menos r 2 x ahora vamos a ver qué pasa
si multiplicamos este por este binomio
menos r 1 por equis tenemos menos r 1 x
y menos cr1 por menos r 2 nos da más
r1 r2 igual a 0 muy bien ahora el chiste
aquí es agrupar de forma correcta
entonces tendremos x cuadrada menos
vamos a factorizar el menos de estas x y
tendremos r1 r2 por x muy bien esto
esencialmente es lo mismo que acá arriba
verdad tendremos menos x r 1 x x es este
término menos x r2 por x es menos r 2x y
luego nos falta sólo sumar r 1 x r 2 y
esto seguirá siendo igual a 0 entonces
pensemos un momento en lo que tenemos
aquí y en lo que teníamos al inicio al
inicio me dice que este coeficiente aún
sería lo equivalente en este caso a
menos r1 y r2 muy bien siguen siendo de
la misma forma los polinomios entonces a
uno sería igual a menos r1 r2 eso que
significa quien sería entonces r1 r2
pues sería menos a uno verdad sí sí a
uno es menos
r1 r2 entonces r1 r2 es menos a uno
entonces este caso no fue no fue difícil
vamos a ver qué pasa con el de tercer
grado ok entonces en el test en el de
tercer grado tenemos un polinomio de la
forma x cúbica más a uno x cuadrada más
a 2x más a 3 igual a 0 y otra vez tú
dirás porque aquí hay un 1 bueno pues
porque si no hubiera un 1 dividimos
entre lo que hubiera como coeficiente de
x al cubo
ahora bien este es un polinomio de
tercer grado y tiene tres raíces r1 r2 y
r3 digamos esto que significa pues que x
menos ere uno al multiplicarlo por x
menos r2 y que luego multiplicamos por x
menos r3 debe ser igual a 0 por lo que
nos dice en esta ecuación muy bien
entonces la pregunta otra vez es quien
es la suma de las raíces de este
polinomio muy bien entonces vamos a
hacer un buén o algo algo breve y algo
rápido si te das cuenta esto de aquí
este producto esencialmente es lo que
calculamos antes entonces lo que
nosotros tenemos que multiplicar es este
polinomio de segundo grado por x menos
r3 entonces no voy a hacer todos los
términos porque solo me van a interesar
algunos ya verás porque digamos que
empezamos a multiplicar con x todo este
polinomio entonces tendremos x x x
cuadrada me da x al cubo
x al cubo muy bien ahora bien qué pasa
si yo multiplico esta x ok digamos que
multiplicó esta x ahora por menos seré
uno más r 2 x digamos por esto entonces
tengo menos r uno más
r 2 que multiplica a x por x que es x
cuadrada muy bien y tendré otros
términos que ya no me no me interesan
realmente ahorita calcular los muy bien
va a haber otros términos eso es lo
único que hay que considerar ahora bien
qué pasa si empezamos a multiplicar
menos r3
por todo esto tendremos menos r 3 x x
cuadrada es menos r 3x cuadrada y
tendremos otros otros términos y ya
verás ahorita porque no me interesa
calcular los demás si yo fuera sumando
bueno esencialmente lo que hay que ver
es que ya no va a haber otros términos
de x cuadrada verdad por ejemplo x
tendría que multiplicarse por este
término que tiene x para obtener
es cuadrada o igual si queremos
multiplicar menos r3 por alguno de estos
y que nos dé x cuadradas solo puede ser
el primero ok entonces los demás van a
ser términos de un grado inferior a 2
ahora bien si nosotros sumamos qué es lo
que nos queda
tendremos x cúbica y aquí podemos
agrupar menos r uno más r 2 más r 3 que
multiplican a x cuadrada más otros
términos que son de grado inferior
ahora bien fíjate muy bien que es lo que
acabamos de obtener acabamos de obtener
que el coeficiente que antecede a x
cuadrada es menos r 1 más r2 más r 3
pero eso debe ser a 1 eso significa que
r1 más r-2 más r 3 debe ser igual a
menos a 1 entonces esto va muy bien con
nuestra idea porque estamos calculando
de forma fácil la suma de las raíces de
polinomios entonces lo que nos gustaría
es bueno qué tal si tenemos un polinomio
n queremos calcular rápidamente cuál es
la suma de sus raíces así que esto lo
vamos a demostrar por inducción vamos a
demostrar que la suma de las raíces es
menos el primer coeficiente después del
grado más grande muy bien que de hecho
sería el de grado uno menor ok entonces
vamos a demostrar esto por inducción
significa que vamos a suponer que esta
regla se cumple para un polinomio de
grado n y vamos a demostrar que se
cumple para el de grado n 1 ok entonces
lo que vamos a suponer vamos a demostrar
por inducción y por lo tanto vamos a
suponer
suponemos lo siguiente digamos que
tenemos un polinomio de grado n x cn más
a 1 x a la n menos uno más todos los
demás términos y esto es igual a cero ok
entonces esta ecuación tiene n raíz es
digamos que son r1 r2 ya está r n muy
bien esto que significaba pues que x
menos r 1 por x menos r 2 que multiplica
a todos estos x menos rn igual a 0 nos
daba lo siguiente nos daba x a la n
menos r1 r2 y así sumamos todos estos
rehenes y que multiplica a x a la n 1
sumamos más términos y esto nos daba
igual a 0
entonces esto es lo que estamos
suponiendo tomamos un polinomio
cualquiera de grado n obtenemos sus
raíces hacemos esta multiplicación y al
desarrollar nos queda una expresión de
este estilo
nos lleva a suponer también que la suma
de las raíces la suma de las raíces r1 y
r2 y sumamos todas hasta rn es menos a 1
entonces con todo esto que hemos
supuesto vamos a ver pensemos ahora qué
pasa si tenemos un polinomio de un grado
mayor entonces pensemos en lo siguiente
pensemos en x a la n 1 + a 1 x a la n
más seguimos sumando hasta no sé hasta
algún hasta algún término y esto es
igual a 0 entonces tenemos nuestro
polinomio de grado n 1 igualado a cero
entonces esto tiene n más un raíz es
verdad r 1
r2 r3 y así hasta rn y r n 1 estas son
nuestras raíces qué significa eso otra
vez que si yo multiplico estos x menos
r1 por x
r2 si voy multiplicando hasta x menos rn
y luego multiplicó por x menos rn uno y
esto lo igual a cero esto al
desarrollarlo nos queda bueno aquí hay
que aquí hay que notar algo y es la
esencia de la prueba de la demostración
esto de aquí esto de aquí justamente es
lo que hemos calculado acá arriba
tenemos exactamente esto entonces lo
único que nos resta es multiplicar este
polinomio por este binomio de aquí muy
bien entonces esa es la idea y vamos a
ver qué es lo que resulta entonces si
multiplicamos x por x a la n lo que nos
queda es x
n 1 ahora si multiplicamos x por este
segundo término lo que tenemos es no se
dejen hacerlo con otro color se va
multiplicamos x por esto
por esto lo que nos queda es x es bueno
sería menos r1 r2 más todos estos más r
n iv x por equis a la enee menos uno es
x a la n muy bien y seguimos con
términos de grado inferior sale ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa si multiplicamos
este de acá
digamos vamos a hacerlo ahora sí vamos a
multiplicar menos rn uno por x a la n
nos quedan menos r n 1 por x a la n y
seguimos sumando términos de grado
inferior entonces al final al final si
sumamos esto si sumamos esto que es lo
que nos queda nos queda
x a la n 1 y luego tenemos que restar r1
y r2 y así hasta r n pero también
restamos ere n 1 aunque entonces como
aquí está el menos tenemos rn + 1 que
multiplica a x a la n y tenemos términos
de grado inferior muy bien entonces lo
que obtuvimos es que otra vez el
coeficiente de de x a la n resulta ser
menos la suma de las raíces muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos con esto es que
la suma de las raíces la suma de todas
estas raíces de este polinomio de grado
n 1 debe ser igual a menos a 1 que es el
coeficiente que antecede
a x a la n es decir uno menos que el
grado máximo muy bien entonces aquí ya
hicimos la demostración por inducción
piensen en lo siguiente si suponemos
cierto para para alguna n demostramos
que para el siguiente es cierto pero con
que empezamos verdad empezamos con en
igualados y después demostramos para n
igual a 3
demostramos para n igual a 3 pero ahora
aquí lo que hicimos es si suponemos
cierto para alguna n demostramos que es
cierto para el siguiente entonces
tenemos que es cierto para tres y por
este argumento es cierto para cuatro
pero como es cierto para cuatro el
siguiente va a ser cierto y que cinco
entonces va a ser cierto para todos los
los grados para todos los grados de los
polinomios en realidad estamos diciendo
que cualquier polinomio cumple esta
propiedad muy bien es como una
demostración por un efecto dominó verdad
sí es cierto para uno lo que tienen las
piezas de dominó es que si las acomodas
y tiras una puedes ir tirando una tras
otra tras otra
así es como demostramos por inducción
supongo si suponemos cierto para uno
resulta que el siguiente también es
cierto entonces ya lo demostramos para
todos ahora piensen lo siguiente tenemos
la suma de las raíces estas raíces
podrían ser complejos pero pero a lo
mejor a uno es un número real así que lo
que está pasando a la hora de sumar
estos es que las partes imaginarias se
están cancelando entonces
no sé quizás quizás valdría la pena
hacer un ejemplo digamos que tenemos
este digamos no sé un polinomio muy raro
no sé este podría ser x a las 7 menos y
x x a las seis más por x a las cinco
menos raíz de 2 x x a la 4 qué sé yo no
sé menos 3 igual a 0 y a lo mejor nos
preguntan hoy cuánto vale la suma de
todas las raíces digamos ser a estévez
un polinomio de grado 7 entonces tiene 7
raíces si nosotros sumamos todas sus
raíces cuánto vale a pues eso nos dice
que es menos el coeficiente de un grado
menor al máximo entonces sería menos
menos piqué es verdad y entonces
realmente esto es una herramienta muy
buena y tú te preguntarás oye pero qué
tal que no me dan un polinomio con el
primer coeficiente igual a uno digamos
que tal que me que me ponen algo así
como 7 quizá las 5 menos 6 x a la 4
y por x al cubo más no sé qué tanto
igual a cero entonces dices cuánto suman
estas raíces bueno recordemos que
podemos dividir todo entre 7 verdad
porque porque realmente no afecta a la
ecuación entonces si dividimos de ambos
lados entre 7
tendremos x a las 5 a las 5 menos 6
entre 7 x a la 4 más pi entre 7 x al
cubo y así sumamos y esto nos da igual a
0 muy bien entonces ahora sí cuáles son
la cuál es la suma de las raíces de este
polinomio de grado 5 pues es menos el
coeficiente de un grado de un grado
menor que el máximo entonces sería r1
el reloj bueno la suma de todas estas
raíces sería 6 séptimos así que espero
que hayas encontrado esto muy divertido
y muy útil